نعم خالد بالفعل وهو ما يفسر حاله القلق
الشديد الذي تنتاب السلطات التركيه
وبالتالي اللجوء الى المجتمع الدولي وطلب
المساعده الدوليه من دول العالم حتى
اللحظه وصل مساعدات من اربعه عشره دوله
ومتوقع ان تصل مساعدات ايضا من عشرات
الدول ربما 70 دوله كما تحدثت السلطات
التركيه في الاحاطه الاخيره وما زالت
عمليات المساعدات عمليات الانقاذ والاجلاء
والاخلاء مستمره حتى هذه الساعه هناك جسر
جوي انشاه الجيش التركي للوصول الى تلك
المناطق النائيه ايضا المناطق المنكوبه
خصوصا مركز الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه
الجنوبيه تحديدا هاتاي وكرمان مارش ودام
اديامان تلك المناطق الاكثر تضررا وتتركز
عمليات الانقاذ في
المناطق هناك اكثر من 5700 مبنى انهار
بشكل كامل وعمليات الانقاذ ما زالت مستمره
لكن الوضع حتى هذه اللحظه خالد حساس وصعب
جدا بسبب
الهزات الارتداديه المستمره والمخاوف من
استمرار هذه الهزات الارتداديه نائب
الرئيس التركي تحدث عن اكثر من 310 هزه
عشره هزات ارضيه
وقعت او حدثت منذ يوم امس وحتى هذه اللحظه
بعضها وصل الى اربعه وخمس درجات على مقياس
ريختر وهناك مباني متصدعه متداعيه نتيجه
الزلزال
الكبير او الزلزال الرئيسي الذي ضرب
البلاد يوم امس وبالتالي هناك مخاوف من
هذه الهزات الارتداديه
وانهيارات جديده قد تلحق بالمباني
المتصدعه لذلك تطلب السلطات التركيه من
المدنيين عدم العوده الى المباني حتى وان
كانت متضر بشكل قليل جدا لان ذلك ربما
يشكل خطوره على حياتهم في اي لحظه من
اللحظات في هذه الاثناء تستمر عمليات
الانقاذ وتتواصل عمليات الانقاذ ايضا هناك
صعوبه اخرى يواجهها السلطات اتواجهها
السلطات التركيه وهي حاله الطقس المترديه
والعاصفه الثلجيه التي تضرب البلاد وتتعمق
شيئا فشيئا وبالتالي هو تحدي اخر يواجه
السلطات التركيه في هذه العمليات امطار
برد وثلوج درجات الحراره تصل الى ادنى او
الى اقل من الصفر وبالتالي هذا تحدي اخر
يواجه السلطات ايضا يواجه المنكوبين
والمدنيين خصوصا في المناطق المنكوبه
لانهم يعني الكثير الالاف من المنكوبين في
العراء تحدثت السلطات التركيه عن 52 الف
تم تامينهم في مراكز ايواء في تلك المناطق
وبالتالي ما زالت عمليات
انقاذ والاجلاء مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه